allo ben qu'est ce que tu fous et les
derniers épisodes là mais je suis bloqué
au boulot bon demain soir je peux finir
plutôt est-ce que ça va attends tu te
rends compte que tu me demandes la
mecque
ça fait cinq ans qu'on regarde la série
ensemble tu m'attends bah ouais je me
sens pas avec toi tu regardes pas tu
maintenant ok
et lui roumanie non c'est quoi cette
tête at est dégoûté pour l'épisode 9
tard tu as vu que c'est qu'ils meurent
non justement j'ai pas vu à temps
je te raconte juste un tout petit tu me
dit rien du tout et pourquoi mais
attends c'est bon il est annoncé je ne
te dis pas de dieu tu dis pas que tu as
vu surtout petit truc dans le genre du
tout mais la première à los cabos pollet
sais pas si finir
écoute c'est très simple pas de pause
café la machine et bains de lavey pas
téléphone ça devrait bien se passer
ok c'est pour bosser moi je n'ai pas à
l'eau tu n'es pas du saloon et moi tu
t'es pas tué
excuse moi tu aurais pas pas de menace
te plaît maintenant j'ai juste de quoi
m'acheter un paquet de chips du coup
c'est mais dis moi t'as pas vu l'épisode
de toi
tu sais quoi je t'invite voilà voilà
passez une bonne journée fait ça lui
fait a fait quoi les ressorts
j'étudie pas et tu dis pas ok tu dis pas
je dis pas perdre
pas un mec faut juste que je te raconte
un truc comme ça se fait que tu es là si
tôt mais je tenais plus personne tu as
volé non tu m'en passer rien du tout
c'est rien du tout je te jure laisse moi
c'est trop tard ils sont sûrs
il est temps que tu saches je vais dire
qu'ils étaient tués tarif on a remonté
et non tu dis pas être ne suffit pas
[ __ ] oh je suis con merde à l'eau
balle comme ouais t'as vu l'épisode 9
toi je peux me raconter